let me ask you a ridiculous question so
you've created some of the greatest
games ever I I think there's there's uh
the question would be what's the best
game of all time all right all right
just give me a second Tetris all right
yeah that's interesting have you read
the book on Tetris no you should read it
particularly if someone grew up in
Russia
yep I'm sure there's an interesting
story the fact that there's a book about
Tetris is fascinating is there a book
about Mario
um I would love to uh I would love to
find out more but I think I would put
Personnel put Skyrim I'll take that good
answer at number one for me
uh which is tough however you put it
because you could also make the case out
of the uh Elder Scrolls series like what
do you actually value more if you put
Tetris and Super Mario up there then
like the credit goes to Morrowind maybe
over Skyrim I don't I don't know where
the biggest leaps are
um but overall I think it's Skyrim well
uh for you if you're not allowed to pick
any of the games you were involved with
what are some interesting candidates for
you that are just games that
inspired the world impacted the world
shook the world in terms of what video
games are able to do
well first
I'm just sort of like hearing you say
that you think Skyrim's the best game of
all time is quite
like thank you and it's you know
incredible thing to hear
um and
you know when I think about
we have a couple answers there's ones
that are like personal to me Ultima
seven it's probably yeah can you talk
about Ultima you said that as an
inspiration I've never crossed that
world well which it was what kind of
game is it it's a role-playing game you
know Circa 1992 93 94 and the Ultima
Online first you know
really visual online World in that way
um but for me that was a virtual fantasy
world where I had you know you could
bake bread you could pick all this stuff
up I mean anyone who's played ultimas
and plays our stuff can see the kind of
uh touchstones and callbacks to that or
inspirations
and the other thing that I loved about
Ultima
was actually the peer they were all
different
right that they iterated and there
weren't necessarily what I'll call A
plus one sequel outside of Ultima 7 part
two clearly a plus one sequel but they
each had their own tone
um I love like the boxes
you know it's something that we get into
as well I love this idea that a game
also is this tangible
thing oh when you but when you buy it
you know the cardboard boxes and the way
they were designed and Ultima 7 is black
and Ultima Eight's the fiery gate and
the paintings on them and I just you
know if you break your heart a little
bit that that culture is a big gone a
little bit a little bit
and that's also why I like
you know this goes to video gaming or
any other digital things where digital
ownership has great value to people so I
like looking at my collections of games
even digitally I want to see nice you
know in the same way you want to see
nice album art I want to see nice cover
art for our games
and we spend a lot of time in them so
that you take a look at Elder Scrolls
and Mormon Oblivion and Skyrim we want
those boxes to look good next to each
other
going back to the video games
yeah you know I always mention Tetris
because I think
it's
you know obviously I love Virtual Worlds
and those kind of things but for the
time and what an interactive like video
game sort of the simplest form
I sort of think you can put Tetris in
front of just about anybody
and
they'll enjoy it
and it's got some moment of Challenge
and
um it's just so elegant it's like to me
the like this very pure game
that only works because it's a video
game
and I think mobile games figured out
some of the magic of Tetris the simple
some of them have yeah yeah and but that
just did it a long long time ago right
you could you can really create that
immersive experience without but for me
you know the ultimate civilization
yeah
um as far as you know a grand strategy
game
um
Pac-Man I mentioned in terms of bringing
games into the mainstream in a way that
captured people that nothing before it
had
Super Mario Donkey Kong everything
Nintendo I probably the best game makers
in the world still
um they know who they are they know what
they want to do
um always in awe of what they create
I gotta ask about a game I haven't
played but people put up there as one of
the greats Zelda breath of the wild have
you got a chance to play a lot of it yes
yes it's fantastic it's fantastic what
do you think about I mean it's a very
different experience I played other
zeldas than the open walls you've
created but it is also an open world it
is uh uh it's my favorite Zelda because
obviously like open World stuff and
the the one thing that they do really
really well is they don't constrain you
some people you know even some of the
things we do can strain you a little bit
more Zelda says here's the whole thing
and you are constrained by the actual
um player abilities you haven't earned
yet not some arbitrary barriers and so I
think they just did a phenomenal job
it's a magical game
it really feels open it's because it it
truly is yes what about I mean I'm just
like asking about some open world uh a
very different one is the world of
either Grand Theft Auto or Red Dead
Redemption both love I would put GTA 3
Grand Theft Auto 3 up there with the
landmark kind of Usher in the open world
when that comes out on the PlayStation
2. even though there was GTA one and two
this was an all new thing with the
mobster storytelling uh 3D version I
guess it was it was then Vice City is
kind of a fast follow which uh
could be my favorite one
um I loved all the Grand Theft Auto I
think they're really phenomenally well
made games same with red dead I think
Red Dead Redemption one
could be my favorite story
like
highly recommend finishing that game see
like both the story you like the
grittiness of that because they have
they have a bit of the
like I guess if you like to fall Fallout
there's the humor the I don't know I
don't know what it is it's the
light-hearted humor of it but also the
brutality of human nature is in there
too but it's like uh
and also some of the fun they create
with the music when you drive and stuff
like that they create they create a
world there's a tone there's a very
strong there's a very strong tone
um you know the satire on the world is
just so well done the gameplay is great
um I think they've just done a
a phenomenal job is there any others
that pop to mine portal portal yeah
that's that's another weird creation I
could just sit here and list games
forever before I'm enjoying this
hearthstone's a game I love I love all
time like sports college football NCAA
Football was my favorite it's like I
would say this is a great role you would
actually keep getting a rule it's a
role-playing game because I have all
these characters I have like you know 60
characters and they're all leveling up
and then I have to play them and then
the college ones are like college
football they'd graduate so you lose
your players and then they stop making
the series and I know the folks at EA
and they will say I have bugged them
when is this coming they're doing it so
it's finally coming back nice what would
you say is the is the is the greatest
sports game of all time hmm
well it's NCAA football I have to pick
the year
versus Madden oh yeah but there's more
teams you get to College you know fight
songs there's more pageantry and the
players turn over they're only there for
Four Seasons so you have to the the the
so you know it's that there's it's more
Dynamic so you like variety versus so
what was the last one 2014 maybe it was
and you don't like FIFA and I like look
FIFA's incredible I just look I'm a
college football fan they give you that
fantasy if you like if you like European
football soccer Fifa is incredible yeah
I love that game too
have you been paying attention to the
game design of that world of those
worlds yeah and the thing people I think
with those kind of games
it is really like we're racing games
Forza put up there I love Forza
um play them all when you are have to
recreate something that's real in the
real world say it's cars or it's sports
games everybody knows how it should work
that's that's a really difficult task
when people know how it should work then
you're going to balance it for single
player the multiplayer parts of it
um they get very very competitive
and you know in many respects you're
forced to put out a new version every
year
and
I say forced in quotes because they're
you know you count them as big updates
but it's a very it's a much more
difficult development process than I
think
um
people understand
and how hard those teams work I know a
lot of people who do it and I think they
just do
I've enjoyed them all I buy Madden every
year
yeah so yeah every single year
yeah they do refresh it there's a
feeling of freshness I don't know what
that is you know look there have been
years where it feels like less was done
and more was done but I enjoy it every
year